I want to leave with a little tribute to
Megan rapino the world's most annoying
sports star who's now retired from
International uh sakur uh and she said
this I feel like the stuff off the field
is um like the reason I'm you know here
on this planet that feels um like my
life's work and um something that um
just feels like breathing to me so um I
love that work um you know I love being
able to let Lage this amazing platform
and um use that to you know in some way
make the world a better place oh shut up
honestly good
forever you kick a round little ball
around that's it nobody wants to you see
you make the world a better place and
let me tell you what she means by this
stuff off the pitch is that now she's
retired now she says she wants to see
biological males who've transitioned to
be trans women play in The Women's
National
soccer team not while she was playing
herself so they couldn't take her place
uh these biological males but now she'd
be quite happy for that to happen fact
she wants it to happen if that's what
your contribution is to women's rights
because she's basically saying look at
me I did all this stuff for women's
rights actually miss rapino what you've
done you've left with a little sting in
the tail is that now having fought for
women's rights from pay parity and so
which I totally applaud you for now
you've left endorsing something that
would destroy women's rights to fairness
and equality that is your legacy anyone
got a thought yeah the progress it's
absolutely absurd to suggest you know
the reason that she's left at this point
is because her life has become so
difficult as she's tried to campaign for
fairness and in equality for trans women
in sports even as she's you know fought
for a very very long time to get through
all of these measures that you've just
said have been really really important
we've reached the stage where the the
political debate about trans people has
become so toxic she feels like out in
order to be har earling harand says I'm
a woman he can play in the women team
number wom team the number of people
going
toang hang on very important question
Grace can earling Harland if he says I
now identify as a woman playing the
Norwegian National women City massive
he's the best rer in the world he's 6'4
he's a massive Beast he scores goals
every 10 seconds in the men's game are
you happy he suddenly decided become
trans go through all of the horror go
the just like self no you go through
nothing he he he self-identifies as
trans he deals with all of the the push
back on social media the death threat
everything that he's going to get as a
result of that and then says I
want then you know the the team would be
able to legitimately make a decision so
whether or not that
was that is exactly that is the Megan
rapino position right there you are our
Megan rapino you've just destroyed
saying that I'm an international women's
soccer player no I'm saying you're
relatively irritating uh taking position
which is always wrong the feeling is mut
and on this one and on this one you have
just endorsed earling Harland playing
women's football which of course would
destroy women's football congratulations
women's rights nil I didn't but look
look power to destroy wom biological sex
matters right yeah and Men Bor born as
men shouldn't be playing in sport but
rapino Free Speech what's wrong with
that she's allow she's allowed to and by
the way nothing wrong with me exercising
my right to free speech to say it's
complete a bit like Grace's position on
ear harand who she only just heard of
complete clap trap a man who can
apparently destroy women's football at
the touch of a hat crazy it would it
would but thank you
p